hey hello ladies how are you hi
i didn't hear where you were from i i'm
sorry we went to canada from canada okay
yeah yeah
i just love
this movie so much congratulations oh
wait did someone say something no i said
i i i'm
and that was awful sorry
i have a canadian friend who says i'm
going home to canadian which always
makes me laugh and that's
well congratulations on winning big at
the gotham awards that's so exciting so
i want to know out of the group of women
here who's the first to celebrate who
wants to party get their champagne on
and who's ready for a good night's sleep
i'd say peter thursgard
he's the first on the dance floor and
the last and the last lead yeah
and you you if you if you have to walk
past him on the dancefloor you try not
to catch his eyes
that's so
so he knows this because when i
interviewed him he also said himself
he said himself in answer to your
question okay then
um you know obviously you get really
close when you work on a film like this
and i just have to say i love this story
so much that dakota gave olivia her
first tattoo i just need to know whose
idea that was
yeah how did it happen
yeah
well we we'd all talked about doing
something together i had i had brought a
stick and poke kit to greece but then it
got take it it got confiscated because
it was large needles
um
so
we didn't get to do it in greece
which was great pierced and i did oh yes
oh you did yeah pierced my septum
as soon as i got home and then i took it
out it was not it didn't work but but
nobody else did it i was like well we
were i was going to do an ear but then i
forgot about that i didn't forget yeah
but then one night in new york i
tattooed olivia
yeah
so exciting it was so exciting
and now we're both later this afternoon
we're going to get huge back tattoos yes
yeah we're going to get species
we're
would you allow olivia to give you a
tattoo
can you allow olivia to touch you
definitely like i'd be so proud thank
you
although i don't know what you would end
up like a friend of mine got a rose on
her back but badly done it looks like a
kind of black sperm just like a little
wiggly thing i know a person who got
strength and courage tattooed on their
wrists but they forgot to draw the r so
it says stank
stink
with and then tried to go back and like
put an r in with like a camera oh one of
those
really stupid
stank then courage
oh no well olivia now knows what to do
what not to do if she ever wants to
tattoo the rest of
so this is just so exciting obviously
critics are loving this film i watched
this movie it's so good
maggie for you with this being your
directorial debut uh you know i can only
imagine the excitement in the nerves but
then you have this fantastic cast this
amazing group of women bringing such
complex characters to life what was this
experience like for you
i mean i remember texting peter on the
first day i was shooting with you
and it was the first day of shooting and
uh i said
this is hard work heaven
oh
oh
that is how i felt it was like it was
like we got in a river
and we just
didn't get out of it until it was
finished and then you guys left and i
went to the editing room and i got in
the river with my editor and we just
kept going down you know i mean it was
like a
i actually still feel like i might be in
that river
so it was amazing i it was it was i
couldn't
i chose people to work with
these actresses my husband
paul
ed harris doug mara you know ollie jack
who uh
helen louvard who was my dp people who
had so much respect for
um that that
everything they did all the time was
inspiring and surprising
and
energizing
and i mean you know what i drink
champagne every night and and like
somebody said to me the other night like
what were you celebrating i was like oh
i was celebrating everything that
happened all day
like
thirsty for champagne every night
every night i was like where are we
having champagne
[Laughter]
on the island uh and you know when
you're bringing these characters to life
olivia what is it like having a
fantastic actress like maggie behind the
lens guiding you with this performance
it makes a huge difference
uh knowing
i was talking to a lovely uh writer
director
friend last night and felt a bit awkward
saying is that loud in front of him
because he's
i said it's being directed by someone
who's already done it makes you feel
they're not asking me to do anything
they would haven't already done or would
do themselves and then you feel extra
safe and you have to feel supported and
safe
and looked after in order to go where
you need to go
and um to do a good job i think if you
feel that you're bullied you bought up
against it yeah it doesn't work and so
that approach is
comedy it's just so bad and uh luckily
it's dying out but it's being directed
by also an actor that i adore and i'm a
huge fan of is it's great
i love that
listen you feel it with all of the
performances dakota was like for you
taking on this role of a mother who so
many parents can relate to in terms of
just the exhaustion you feel when you're
raising a human being
i think it felt just the most honest to
me it felt like
oh i know
that woman
i know those are my friends that's my
mother you know it's
it i
it felt like the truth and i
um
that's so much of what i think all of us
are interested in as artists is
having the opportunity to
say something that
deeply resonates with you as a as an
artist and as a person
and also is
like
almost offers a hand to the viewer to
make them feel that it's okay to have
complicated feelings
yeah absolutely
jessie did you talk to olivia before
crafting these characters because your
mannerisms are just so in sync i love it
so much both of your characters are so
good
we did not really no sorry
we just chose an accent and then we were
just we we shot separately so i was i
yeah and i'm no we didn't no but that's
lovely but i wonder if that's testament
as well to the writing so you sort of
know who she is it's very yeah
and
uh
i mean if we'd come up with very
different versions
i would have been absolutely rubbish at
that as well like you know you've said
how bad i am at picking up a phone in
one
off your arm and then you cut off your
arm and try and march together i mean it
would be such a waste it would be so
weird and also they're not the same
person everyone knows it
i think in some ways if you were like
trying to make them you put on the
contact lenses and you do the every it
feels fake people go like what instead
they're very different i mean they're
extremely different in the movie and
and in fact it makes no difference
we like the movie asks you to believe
that
for the purposes of our story for two
hours that this is the same woman at
different times in her life you know
and and that's all like in a kind of a
poetic agreement that they're so
different and it's true jessie are you
there you would never trust i would have
been fired after two days you hated me i
can tell i wouldn't imagine a look in
your face if i had been trying to get
you to act like olivia
and vice versa
yeah
well i just have to say everyone
oh thank you very much yeah so thanks so
much you guys are so much fun and
congratulations on all the success thank
you so much nice to meet you bye-bye bye
nice back to you guys